So we were talking about
the beta distribution and
the gamma distribution separately.
And I mentioned that they're connected but
we haven't seen, how is
beta connected to gamma other than being
consecutive letters of the Greek alphabet?
So there's one very, very
famous example that connects the beta and
the gamma in a very neat way.
So that seemed like a natural
starting point to bring the beta and
the gamma together.
Another thing we haven't done yet
is figure out the normalizing constant for
the beta distribution,
except in the special cases where we
could use Bayes Billiards arguments.
So we want to have the normalizing
constant in general for beta and gamma.
So, here's an example, it's a story
that connects the beta and gamma.
I call it a bank and post office.
You can call it whatever you want.
I just like having a concrete
example in mind and for
some reason I call this
the bank post office example.
So the idea is you have to go
to the bank and do something.
You have to go to the post office and
do something.
Both of them you have to wait in line for
some amount of time.
And let's define some notation.
So let's say first you go to the bank and
you wait for
a total of X minutes to be served and
suppose that X is
gamma of a lambda.
If a is an integer, I didn't just
like randomly write down gamma,
there would be a natural
interpretation here.
If a is an integer,
let's gamma five lambda.
Remember we saw that
the gamma five lambda,
you can think of it as the sum of
five i.i.d exponential lambda.
So that would be like
the assumption that everyone,
there's five people in line before you and
each of them takes an exponential
lambda amount of time to be served.
And there's only one line and
we could wait in line and
then eventually your turn.
Okay, and then let y be gamma
of b lambda same thing.
X is how long you wait, that's your
waiting time to be served at the bank.
And Y is your waiting
time at the post office.
And we'll assume they're independent.
X is independent of Y,
that's the assumption.
So that's a statement of the set up.
Now the question is, first of all,
what's the distribution,
Of your total waiting time?
And let's call that T, T for total.
That we already actually know.
At least for the integer case.
If a and b are integers,
this is the sum of a i.i.d exponentials.
This is the sum of b i.i.d exponentials.
So together they must be
a plus b i.i.d exponentials.
So just from that story you immediately
say that it's gamma a plus b,
lambda and
we don't have to do anything else.
If it's not an integer, you could just
to the MGF, that we also did, and
just multiply the MGFs.
And again, that will confirm
gamma of a plus b lambda.
All right, so that was easy.
We didn't need to do anything.
But suppose, another natural thing to look
at, is the fraction of time, that's just
of your total waiting time, what fraction
of that was spent waiting at the bank?
That's another natural thing to look at.
I'll just call this thing W
just to have a name for it.
I want the distribution of
these two things, not just one.
Since there's two of them, actually
what we want is the joint distribution.
We already know that the marginal
of this is gamma a plus b lambda.
We don't yet know the distribution of W,
and we don't yet
know the joint distribution.
So you might think to yourself
a little bit, if you had to guess,
do you think that the total time
spent waiting is independent or
dependent of the fraction of
time spent waiting at the bank?
Do you wanna guess?
How many of you think
that they're independent?
Okay, just guessing.
And how many of you
think they're dependent?
Okay, pretty close.
It's not obvious.
At least I don't think it's obvious.
So we have little calculation to find out
cuz I don't think it's intuitively obvious
one way or the other whether
they're independent or not.
They don't look independent cause you have
the X plus Y here, but on the other hand
just knowing how long you waited, what
does that tell you about the fraction?
So, you can make an argument either way,
it's not going to resolve the question.
So let's actually let lambda equal
1 just to simplify notation.
It's not really any harder
with general lambda,
just more notation floating around.
For the general case, anyway,
we talked about the fact that you
could go from gamma a1 to gamma a lambda,
just by dividing by lambda.
So at the end of the day,
if we want to put lambdas back,
we could put lambdas everywhere.
It's not gonna affect W, because you're
kind of scaling everything by the same
factor, it's gonna cancel out anyway.
And then this one would be gamma a plus
b lambda instead of gamma a plus b1.
It's just a scaling thing, so
this doesn't really lose any generality.
All right.
So now we just find the joint PDF.
Okay, so here's the joint PDF.
F sub TW of t,w equals.
So we're gonna start with
the joint PDF of x and y.
And then we need to adjust it by
multiplying by this Jacobian, so
we're gonna have to do a Jacobian.
Probably this is the last
Jacobian I'll ever do in
lecture, but we do need one here.
So there's gonna be this Jacobian thing,
d x,y
d tw.
Se we just need to compute
these things and then simplify.
So, first of all the joint,
because I assumed x and
y are independent the joint PDF of x and
y will just multiply the PDF
of x times the PDF of y.
That's very straightforward.
Just a gamma 1 over gamma of a.
I'll just put the two normalizing
constants here those are both gammas.
Remember the gamma PDF is x
to the a e to the minus x.
And then we have the one for y,
y to the b, e to the minus y.
And then there was an extra one over xy.
Just in the gamma PDF.
Times this Jacobian thing.
Which we'll fill in.
All right.
Let's do the Jacobian.
Here are the transformations
written with capital letters but
let's write the corresponding
thing with lowercase letters.
That is we have x plus y equals t.
And we have x over x plus y equals w.
I think it's a little bit
easier if we invert this and
solve for t, solve for x and y in terms
of t and w, and that's not hard to do.
Because, notice from this second equation,
that's just x over t.
To the denominators t.
So x over t = w, so x = w.
So that's just easy algebra.
And let's solve for y.
If we take one minus this, we get,
take one minus on both sides.
So I'll just write that separately.
y over x + y = 1- w.
I just took one minus on both sides.
But that's just y over t.
So y = t 1- w.
So that's what the transformation is,
it is in the other direction, right?
So, okay,
now we just need to do a 2x2 determinant.
We take this notation means
take the derivatives of x and
y with respect to t and w.
So let's start with the x,
take the derivative with respect to t and
we'll get w.
Take the derivative with respect to w and
we'll get t.
Now, go tot he y, take the derivative
with respect to t, that's 1- w.
And then the derivative with respect to w,
that's really just t- tw
derivative with respect to w,
let's write that down, t- tw.
Now we're taking the derivative
with respect to w, so
we're treating that part as a constant.
And so then we would just have- t.
Okay, and then we do the determinant,
that times that minus that times that.
So that's- tw, and then- t times 1- w.
So it's- tw, and it's-- tw, tw's cancel.
The only thing that's left is this -t.
So the Jacobian simplifies really nicely,
it's just- t.
All right, and then in the Jacobian
formula, we're actually doing
these absolute value bars here
are kind of serving a double purpose.
That means, take the determinant and
then take the absolute value.
Sometimes you might see it written with
like double or little bars like that,
which looks kind of ugly.
But just to remind you, to take
the determinant, take the absolute value,
we don't want a negative PDF.
Also, so that's just t here, so I don't
need to write the absolute value signs.
T is positive, so we're using t, not -t.
All right, so now we have the joint PDF.
The only thing we have to do that that's
left is to write this in terms of t and
w, cuz we still have xs and ys here.
So I'm just gonna plug in, Plug in the
definition of x and y in terms of t and w.
So x is tw, so that's,
let's just write the w stuff first.
So that's w to the a, and this one, y, I'm
just plugging in what I wrote for y there.
That's 1- w to the b.
Then, we also had, because it was tx,
we have t to the a, t to the b,
so that's t to the a + b.
Exponential is e to the- of x + y.
But x + y is just t,
so that's e to the -t.
So this is starting to
look like a gamma PDF.
And then this stuff at the end, x,
well let's see, x is tw,
so we're gonna have and y,
this has a t, so we have 1 over
t cuz it's t over t squared.
And then we also have an extra w and
an extra 1- w.
So we'll just write that, a- 1 and b- 1.
And is that everything?
We can put a 1 here.
So I was just trying to write is as
a function of w times a function of t.
I was trying to do that.
Well, actually, I did do that.
So that's a function of w times a function
of t, therefore, they're independent.
Not at all obvious, but now we just
proved that they're independent.
Okay, well,
the next question is what's the PDF?
Well, we already knew this was a gamma
a + b lambda, and this confirms that.
The only thing that's kind of weird about
this is we don't have the normalizing
constant.
And I was discussing this in office hours
Wednesday night with a couple people like,
where's the normalizing constant?
And my answer is,
if you don't see the normalizing constant,
you can always just multiply by 1, right?
So I'll just put it there, gamma a + b.
Well, of course, I can only do that if I
multiply and divide by the same thing,
so I'll put back gamma of a+b here.
Writing it this way,
now this is exactly the gamma of a+b1 PDF.
All right, so some conclusions from this.
First of all, they're independent.
Secondly, let's find the marginal PDFs.
If we integrate this thing,
Let's get the marginal PDF of w.
So remember to get the marginal PDF,
we just integrate the joint PDF.
And that's actually an easy integral.
[COUGH] So we're just gonna
integrate this joint PDF dt, right?
Integrate out the t,
then we'll get the marginal of w.
[COUGH] But that's an integral
you can do in your head, so
I'm not gonna rewrite this whole thing.
Because imagine sticking
an integral sign here,
we're integrating dt, so this whole thing,
this is a function of w.
So since this integral is dt,
you just take out this entire function,
it's just serving as a constant.
All we're left with then in
the integral is the integral of this,
that's the gamma PDF.
We already know it integrates to 1.
So the integral is just gamma of
a + b over gamma of a gamma of b,
w to the a- 1, 1- w of the b- 1.
As a consequence of that, we've actually
just derived the normalizing constant of
the beta, it has to be this.
Notice that this is a beta
ab up to a constant.
We didn't know what the constant was yet.
Now we know what the constant is,
because if this were the wrong constant,
then this would not be
a valid marginal PDF.
But we just proved that
this is the marginal PDF.
If it's the marginal PDF,
it has to integrate to 1.
So that's the normalizing
constant of the beta.
Okay, so in particular this tells us,
first of all,
now we know the normalizing
constant of the beta.
It didn't look like we set out to, a lot
of times in math you kind of just discover
something that you're not trying to do.
You can't solve a problem, so
you try to solve some other problem and
then you can't solve it, but
you learn something else.
So like that here, like We were just like,
this is a pretty natural
problem with gammas.
If you just try directly to find
the normalizing constant, the beta,
you're faced with a very
different difficult integral.
In this case, we just happen to
notice that the marginal was beta.
And we got this normalizing constant for
free essentially.
And we also know that T is Gamma(a+b1).
And W that is Beta(a,b) and
they're independent.
So that's a very special
property of the gamma and beta,
how they fit together in that way.
Actually, there's a theorem that
essentially says, if you replace this
gamma by any other distribution,
these will not be independent anymore.
That's hard to prove.
But that happens to be true.
This is a very, very special
property of the gamma and the beta.
Okay, so just as an example
of how you might use this,
which actually relates
to the next homework.
In general, so suppose we want
to find the expected value of W,
where W, using the same notation,
W is Beta(a, b).
There's two ways to do it.
One would be to use LOTUS.
And, I'm not gonna write
out the LOTUS right now,
because that should be automatic,
unconscious by now.
Hopefully, you could all write
down the LOTUS really easily and
you can visualize what
would the LOTUS look like.
Well, it just means you're integrating,
well,
it's not even LOTUS,
it's just the definition.
But in fact,
if you wanted e of w to the 12th or
something, that's gonna be
just as easy just using LOTUS.
But just for the mean,
you'd write down the PDF times w, right?
So that would just become w to the a.
But that still looks like a beta, right?
So once you're comfortable with
the pattern of the beta distribution,
you can just write down the answer.
As long as w power, 1-w a power,
it's still gonna look the same.
From the expected value of w to the 100th
power, it's not anymore difficult,
cuz then you're just adding 100 up here,
but it still looks the same.
So once you understand what
the beta distribution looks like,
then you can do it that way.
As I said, that's one way to do it,
I'll also just say LOTUS/definition.
But there's a cooler way to do it.
I drew a line here which means
that that problem was over and
we're starting a new here thing.
And we just have W as Beta(a, b), and
we've forgotten all
the stuff above the line.
But we can remember the stuff
that was above the line.
That's okay, right?
Because the expected value, that's what
I mean, a distribution has to have, if
it has an expected value at all, it has to
be some well- determined expected value.
It's not like you do this with one
particular beta random variable and
you get one thing, and you do with another
one and you get another thing, right?
If you have a beta random variable,
there is a well-defined thing, so
I can choose my favorite way
to generate a beta, all right?
I can choose any way I want
as long as it's beta(a,b).
Well this right here is my favorite
way to generate a beta(a,b).
So I may as well choose that one.
So now, even though this w
didn't necessarily have to have
that interpretation, we can choose
to give it that interpretation.
Because that won't affect
the expected value.
So if we interpret it that way,
we have E (x / x + y).
= E (x) / E (x + y), not by linearity,
that's not linearity.
This is actually one of the most
common mistakes in probability,
is to write this kind of
thing without justification.
So you have a homework
question about this.
Usually, if I write E of something over
something is E of the numerator over
E of the denominator, usually,
that's completely wrong.
So I'll just say be very careful, I'll
show you why this is true in this case.
I'm using the same notation as up there.
So I'm not gonna rewrite
all the all the notation.
That's gamma A1, and
that's gamma B1, same notation.
Usually, this will be a horrible,
horrible blunder.
In this case, this is true.
The reason that that is true is that,
so why is that true here?
Why is E(x/x+y),
let's write it the other way,
put the E(x+y) on the other
side of the equation.
E(X) in this special problem,
I'm not saying this is always true.
In the special problem of gammas, and
I'll just call it the Gamma-Beta or
the bank post office.
Well, usually this is wrong.
However, we have a very important factor
which is that T was independent of W.
So we know that X / X + Y for
this particular problem
is independent of X + W, X + Y, right?
The fraction is independent
of the denominator,
and independent of the total.
Therefore they're uncorrelated,
independent implies uncorrelated.
Definition of uncorrelated for
two random variables X and
Y is equals E of X, E of Y.
So that says uncorrelated.
This being uncorrelated of this just
says that this times this is E of
this times this, but when you multiply
X over X + Y by X + Y, you get X.
So it's true because they're uncorrelated.
By the way, I mean,
that tells us the answer is just a/a+b.
Because we already know that
the mean of the gamma a1 is a.
And you could use linearity
in the denominator, or
use the fact that that's gamma of a+b1.
Okay, so the expected value of
beta is a over a plus b, a to ab.
Similarly, you can get the variance, or
various other functions of the beta.
Okay, so those are the main
things about gamma and beta.
So let's go on to our next big topic,
which is order statistics.
I tried thinking of a good segue
from beta to order statistics.
But it's kind of, it's closely connected.
But you won't see why until we get
to the end of order statistics,
not the beginning of order statistics.
The beta will come up again,
though, so don't worry.
You haven't said goodbye
to the beta forever.
All right, so
let me tell you what order statistics are.
We've already seen some order statistics.
You had a difficult homework problem
about the maximum and the minimum.
Meant to be difficult, but
meant to make you think, right?
One key insight from that is that
the covariance of the max and
the min is not the covariance of x and y.
You can't make the argument that one of
them's the x, and the other one's the y,
and so on.
So that was meant to get you to start
thinking about order statistics.
This is gonna be the more generalization
of that kind of thing with the max and
the min.
So if we have random variables,
X1 through Xn,
and let's assume that they're i.i.d.
And this is just the definition right now.
Order statistics means we
put them in order, and
then those are the order statistics.
Which sounds pretty simple but
you really have to think carefully at
what does it actually mean to do that.
That is hopefully for the homework and
other stuff with the maximum and
the minimum.
You started thinking that what is it
actually mean to think as the max x,y
as a random variable, right?
Anyone can take the maximum of two
numbers just take the bigger number.
What's the maximum of two random
variables that surround variable and
hopefully you've thought by
now what actually that means.
Well, I'll talk about the more
general version here.
So order of statistics are X(1),
this is just notation, X(1) less than or
equal to X(2) less than or equal to blah,
blah, blah, less than or equal to X(n).
So we put this is the standard notation,
where you subscript them
with parentheses where this
notation means that X1 is the minimum,
Right?
And then X2 is the second smallest,
X3 is the third smallest and
so on, all the way up to Xn.
Let's put Xn, yeah,
all the way up to Xn is the maximum.
So those are the two extreme
order statistics, the max and
the min, but then we have everything in
between is also of great interest, right?
For example, the median, right?
Median is a familiar concept.
That's just so you don't take all these
values, take the one in the middle.
So there's some ambiguity about
how to define median if n is even,
which is not really relevant for
our purposes here.
But if n is odd and let's say you had five
numbers and you asked for the median,
it's just the middle number.
That would be the third one, right?
So the median is,
X sub n+1/2,
that will be the middle number.
If there's an even number, different
people use different conventions.
The most common thing would be to take the
two middle numbers and then average those.
But anyway, point is,
we can get the median.
We can get other percentiles,
let's call it a quantile and so on.
Quantile, just think of percentiles.
You can find the one that 75% of
the observations are below that
point that kind of thing.
Median's right at the middle
at the 50 percentile, right?
So, okay, so
those are the order statistics.
And there's a huge literature on
order statistics, a huge amount of
applications of order statistics in
statistics, because it's just a natural
thing that a lot of times you have data
and you don't necessarily care about.
The data might have come to you
independently in this particular order,
but you may not care about that.
I mean, and
often you want to rank things, right?
And look at the largest, the smallest,
the middle value, things like that.
Interquartile range is a famous
concept in statistics.
That just means take the 75th
percentile minus the 25th percentile.
Things like that.
All kinds of statistical quantities are
defined in terms of order statistics, so
we wanna be able to say something
about their distribution.
That's actually a pretty hard problem,
though.
The main reason that they're
difficult to work with,
Since they are dependent.
Even though that's the one key insight
about order statistics in fact,
they're gonna be positively correlated.
Even though we started with i.i.d.,
there still dependent.
Why?
Well,
it's like you saw in the homework, the
maximum is always bigger then the minimum.
So if you know that
the minimum is really big,
that forces the maximum to be even bigger.
And that same argument extends to any,
if I tell you X the third-order statistic,
well the seventh-order statistic
is even bigger than that.
So they give you information
about each other.
So we have to be very careful
about that dependence.
And also they're tricky
in the discreet case, so
we're mostly gonna assume
the continuous case.
Discreet case we have to worry about ties,
that is two random
variables being exactly equal, that's
a serious issue in the discrete case.
In the continuous case which we're
gonna talk about for the rest of today.
Then we don't have to worry about that
issue cuz the probability is zero that
two continuous random variables will
be exactly equal to infinitely many
decimal places.
Okay, so
now let's assume that they're continuous.
And let's derive the distribution
of one of the order statistics.
So let's let X1 through Xn be i.i.d.,
continuous let's say they have
a PDF little f and CDF capital F.
And we wanna find the CDF and
the PDF of the kth order statistic
CDF and PDF, Of X(j)
with parenthesis, okay?
So just for getting the maximum and
the minimum is not too difficult.
And you've already done similar
sorts of problems before.
Like if you want, if you say that
the maximum is less than some number,
say ten that's the same thing as saying
that they are all less than ten and
then use independence.
But we wanna get all and
any of them, right, any extra.
This is gonna be the marginal, right now.
So another, since they're dependent,
we would also like to know
the joint distributions, but
let's focus on the marginal for now.
All right, so let's do the CDF.
So we wanna know what's the probability
that X( j )is less than or
equal to some number X,
i t's the definition of CDF.
And I find, for
working with order statistics,
it really helps to draw a picture.
So we just have a number line,
we have some number X, and
let's just interpret this
event in terms of a picture.
This says that the jth order
statistic is to the left.
Maybe it's over here somewhere.
Of course the other order statistics
like X( j )- 1 are even smaller.
Maybe X(1) is over here, right?
So the first j order statistics
All have to be to the left.
Now it could be that xj
plus 1 is over here, and
it could be that it's over there,
we didn't specify, right?
So I'll say here that there may be more.
We could draw two pictures, one where
actually xj plus one, and xj plus two, and
xj plus three are over here.
And finally, xj plus four crosses over x.
Or we could draw another picture where xj
plus one is already to the right of x.
Either way, this event has occurred.
So in words,
Just by looking at pictures like this and
then interpreting it in words.
Notice that the saying the jth order
statistic is less than or equal to x,
is exactly the same thing
as saying that at least,
j of the let's say Xi's are less than or
equal to x, right?
Cuz we need to have j of them to the left,
maybe more than j, that's okay,
right, but at least j.
So that's exactly the same event.
Now we can actually just write
down a formula directly.
If there's at least j of them,
let's actually specify it more and
say how many are there?
Well let's suppose there are k of them,
so k goes from j to n.
So I'm just gonna break this
up into disjoint cases.
Where the cases are counting how
many of these X's are to
the left of little x, right?
Just breaking it up into cases.
Okay, so assume there are exactly k.
What's the probability of that happening?
Let's say it a different way.
What's the distribution?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> It's a binomial distribution.
How are you defining your success?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Success means to the left of X,
failure means to the right of X.
So this says, this is at least
j successes where we're gonna
sum that up over exactly k successes,
k goes from j to n.
So it's just a binomial.
n choose k, the probability
of success is the probability
of being to the left of X,
by definition that's just the CDF.
So this is F(x) to the k (1- F(x)),
that's the probability of failure,
to the n- k.
So that's the CDF.
Now of course, once we have the CDF,
we can get the PDF by taking
the derivative of this.
But that's gonna be this big ugly sum and
I'm too lazy to try to simplify that sum.
So let's do the PDF a different way.
You get the same answer.
It just takes some work
to deal with that sum.
So I'd rather think more directly.
All right, so here's the PDF.
How do we get the PDF?
Well I'm just gonna draw a picture and
think about what it means.
So, all right, here's the picture.
PDF of xj, let's call it fx(j) PDF (x) =,
and let's just write down the answer,
cuz that's a nicer way to do it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, here's x.
We want the PDF at x.
Now, we have to be a little bit careful
that, Density is not probability,
like the density could be
greater than one and all that.
But we talked about the fact
before that if you take a PDF and
multiply it by some tiny increment,
then that's essentially
the probability that the random variable
is in a tiny interval of that length.
That is, imagine this tiny,
I'm drawing the interval big enough so
that you can see it.
But imagine this is a tiny,
tiny interval of length dx.
So it's infinitesimally small, okay?
And so
we're actually gonna look at F(x) dx.
As we're just multiplying by
the width of that interval and
then we're letting it go to zero.
We're letting it taking
a limit essentially.
Now we can interpret this as saying
the probability that the j order
statistic is in this tiny interval, okay?
Now let's just think about
how could that happen.
Well, first of all it
means that one of these
observations must lie
in this tiny interval.
So we'll take n there're n choice for
which one?
That is this could've been,
one of them has to be here, right?
Good chance to use the pink chalk again.
One of them has to be like right here,
somewhere in this tiny little interval.
There're n choices for
which one goes there.
Now assume that that, and that has
probability f(x)dx of actually happening.
Okay, then let's look at the rest.
There're n- 1 observations left.
This is supposed to be
the jth order statistic.
So that means there must be j- 1 of them,
To the left.
Right?
j- 1 of them are anywhere to the left
of this tiny, tiny interval.
One of them is in this interval and
then the rest of them are to the right.
So that's n- j of them.
Now we chose one of them
that went right there,
we need to choose which
ones are to the left.
So, there're n- 1 left to choose from and
we can choose any j- 1 of them.
Then we just need to know well what's
the probability that those specific j,
now you can imagine that we chose specific
set of j minus 1 of these observations.
They all need to go to the left.
So just F(x), that's the probably
of being to the left of
X to the j- 1 times (1- F(x)),
To the n- j, because this n
minus j need to be to the right.
So just to simplify this a little bit,
the PDF is n(n- 1, choose j- 1) F(x).
It's kind of a neat looking formula,
because it involves both the CDF and
the PDF.
So the CDF to a power,
1 minus the CDF to a power, and the PDF.
So you can also take the derivative
of this and you'll still have a sum,
but if you do some algebra on the sum
it'll simplify to this eventually.
Okay, so that is the marginal PDF.
I was tempted to put on on the homework
a similar problem with the joint PDF
of two order statistics.
I didn't put it on the homework but
I still think it's good practice.
Maybe I'll put it on
the strategic practice.
I haven't posted the next
strategic practice yet, but
I'll do that sometime tonight.
Maybe I'll put this on it, maybe I won't.
But what I'm trying to say is what
if you wanted the joint PDF of
like the third order statistic and
the seventh order statistic?
You could draw a picture Like this except
that then you have to say you kind of
have two of these infinitesimal intervals
and you do an analogous argument.
You can get joint PDF that way,
there's other ways to do
the joint distributions too.
In stat 110, we're mainly concerned with
the marginal ones as long as you keep in
mind that they are dependent.
Okay, so let's do a quick example.
The easiest example to think about, but
it's also a very useful example just to
have in mind is the uniform
order of statistics.
So, let's select U1 through Un
the iid uniform between 0 and 1,
And we wanna find the distribution
of the J order statistic.
So F sub u, j of x.
The PDF of the j order statistic.
I'm just gonna apply this result.
So, okay, well,
that just says n times n- 1 choose j- 1.
F(x), remember that the CDF for
the uniform just increases linearly,
cuz the PDF is a constant.
So that's just x to the j- 1,
1- x to the n- j.
And the PDF is just one,
at least this is for x between 0 and
1, 0 otherwise, Well,
that should look kind of familiar, right?
x to the power, 1 minus x to a power.
I don't even care about, the constant
is just whatever it has to be,
to make it integrate to 1.
And you can check that this is consistent
with the constant we derived earlier,
but the key part of this is this,
it's a beta.
So we know that u sub parenthesis j,
the jth order statistic
is beta j n- j + 1.
Which relates back to something
we did a while ago with
the expected difference
between two uniforms.
So we did this calculation
when we were doing 2D Lotus.
The expected value of u1- u2, right,
and I drew this little picture here.
And I said, okay, one of them could
be there, one of them could be there.
One-third, two-thirds, so on average,
the difference would be one-third.
So, okay, so what was I really doing?
Well, another way to say this
is that the expected value.
The absolute difference
is the max minus the min,
as you were thinking
about on the homework.
So that's the expected max of u1,
u2- the expected min of u1,
u2, but according to this the maximum
is distributed as beta of 2,1.
And the minimum is
distributed as beta of 1, 2.
So this has mean two-thirds, and
this has mean one-third equals one-third.
So that just confirms
the earlier result that,
instead of having to do with
a 2D LOTUS and things like that,
we just say, we recognize this
as a difference of two betas,
the max is not independent of the minimum,
but linearity always holds.
So that's nice.
All right, one last thing,
just to give you something
to think about over the weekend,
if you don't have enough to think about.
So our next big topic is
conditional expectation.
In a sense, you already know what
conditional expectation is if you
understand conditional probability,
because it just means take expectation,
Using conditional distribution
rather than using the distribution.
So for example,
we're gonna use this notation,
E(x|A), where A is an event.
On Monday I will talk more
about what this means.
But I claim that this is something that
should already understand, cuz it just
says use the conditional distribution,
given A, right, so it's basically saying
we're already familiar with, but I will go
into a lot of detail about its properties.
For example,
we can say that E(x) = E(x|A)P(A),
where A is any event,
+ E(x|A complement) given P(A complement),
which looks completely like
the law of total probability,
except they were using expectation
instead of probability.
And in the discrete case, just to quickly
see how would you prove something
like this, in the discrete case,
we'd have the expected value is the sum of
values times their probabilities, all we
would have to do is expand this using,
The law of total probability.
That is,
we would break this up into two terms, and
then just break it into two sums and
you get to this.
So this is a pretty intuitive formula I
think, we'll go into more detail about it.
It's just the expectation version
of the log total probability.
All right so one quick little puzzle for
you to think about, and
is called the Two Envelope Paradox.
I think this paradox
is much more deserving
of the name Paradox than like, Monty Hall.
Luckily, people don't usually say
the Monty Hall Paradox, but if they did,
this one is more deserving
of the name Paradox.
Here's the problem.
I'll just tell you the problem quickly,
we wont' try to solve it today since
there's not time, but
anyway it's fun to think about.
You're given two envelopes.
Each envelope contains a check for
some amount of money.
You're given that one envelope
contains exactly twice as much
money as the other one.
Twice as much money as the other,
but it's symmetrical.
The envelopes look the same,
you can't judge the thickness or anything.
They look completely identical to you,
it's symmetric.
All that you know is that one of them
has double of the other one, okay.
They both have some positive
amounts of money, okay.
So you get to pick one.
Well, so far there's not, pick either
one you want, it's symmetrical.
Let's just say you pick that one, okay.
Now, first assume you get to, there
are variations where you get to open it,
variations where you don't.
First assume you get to open it,
let's assume there's $100 there.
Then you're given the question like
in Monty Hall, do you wanna switch?
So you might reason, while the other one,
you know this ones 100 now.
The other one, it could be 50,
it could be 200.
Seemingly, those are equally likely.
So if your average 50 and 200, you get
$125, which means you should switch.
Now, that argument did not depend
on this being a $100, though.
So let's just call this one x,
the other one is either half x or 2x.
The average of half x and 2x is greater
than x, so you should switch, but
in that case,
why bother even opening the envelope.
That's gonna be some value x, the other
one, on average, is greater than x,
so you should switch to that one.
But then you should switch back, right?
And then you switch forever and
that's not good, all right.
So have a good weekend.